hey guys it's Friday which means I've
got five of this week's biggest stories
to get you all caught up on what's been
going on here's the best one well here's
the title sequences in the first one
very nice want you to tell them what
game you want them to make next the
company is currently running a survey to
find out what games you play what media
you consume and things like that but one
particularly interesting question asks
what one game would you most want Square
Enix to make in the future here you can
alter as you please and write in
anything that strikes your fancy if you
have a little time on your hands and
feel like filling out the 22 questions
survey you can find a link on the Final
Fantasy twitter page next up we've
uncovered why Batman Arkham Knight
earned itself an M for Mature rating in
the UK and the answer is a little gory
it has since the rating which restricts
gamers under 18 from purchasing the game
in the region was granted due to mild
profanity and several scenes of torture
one such scene occurs on an operating
table while another is described by the
ratings board in the following quote a
vehicle's wheels are also used to
torture an enemy in one sequence
developer Rocksteady who've said these
themes are essential to the story so
they're happy to cop the mature ratings
Arkham Knight launches on june seconds
on xbox one ps4 and PC
as for this weekend awesome cheap stuff
if you haven't picked yourself up a new
generation console yet there are some
really good deals around if it's an xbox
one you want then head to Amazon where
350 bucks will currently buy you the
console itself a three-month
subscription to xbox live gold a copy of
NBA 2k15 as well as assassins creed
black flag and Assassin's Creed unity if
the ps4 is more your jam gamester are
currently offering up the console with
destiny and the last of us for four
hundred and ten bucks so that should
keep you busy speaking of destiny
whether you love it or hate it the game
is just earned itself a pretty sweet
accolade having won the BAFTA Awards the
game of the year destiny had some stiff
competition for the award since it was
up against shadow of Mordor dragon age
inquisition alien isolation mario kart 8
and monument valley other winners
included the last of us left behind for
story shadow of Mordor of the game
design and the vanishing of Ethan Carter
for gain innovation finally this week
saw a slew of game delays affecting
project cars homefront two and uncharted
for project cars is now expected in
mid-may having been hit with its Birds
delay while homefront two is had its
release date revised from sometime this
year to sometime next year on chocolate
has been pushed back from this year to
spring of next year with developer
Naughty Dog explaining that they need
more time to deliver the title they've
promised Naughty Dog have said that the
game is extremely ambitious and they
don't want to disappoint gamers with a
half-baked version of their vision game
directors Bruce Straley and Neil
druckmann up
thing to reveal more of the game over
the next year they've said the team at
Naughty Dog will be heads down working
through 2015 making sure that Nathan
Drake's story gets the closure it
deserves let me know down in the
comments if you reckon destiny deserve
to win the bastard game of the year of
wood or which other game you think
should have won and why this week on
site I'll give you a roundup of all the
VR and out so far on gist we tell you
some of our favorite packs games and in
two minutes delves into metal gear story
those are all the things that I wanted
to tell you about this week as always
thanks for sticking around and be sure
to have yourselves a lovely weekend